okay your name is Rita Rita way from
early 2000 Arizona and tell me about
your your childhood you grew up with
both your parents no I just grow with my
mama and she drink a lot have a parties
and I don't want to be with nobody but
my mom and when I had her died I had to
live in a hospital when did your mom
pass away when I was 12 years old and I
wanted to die with her but I couldn't
they put me in the hospital but I tried
to get in a castle with her and they put
me to sleep when I woke up I was in the
hospital they shoot me with some stuff
and now I gotta take it all my life
it's Thursday so easy you tried to get
in the casket yeah with your mom yeah
and I wouldn't let her go but they put
me there sleeping when I woke up I was
in the hospital
it's called poverty hospital poverty
Street Tucson Arizona so see your mom
passes away at twelve and you went where
and I went to Palo Verde Hospital in
Tucson Arizona and did not live this the
County Hospital Oh Tucson Medical Center
and the mental hospital
oh you were to a mental hospital yeah I
lived in like the Exodus and Paul other
I don't know the other name I wasn't
able to take care of myself
until I was 52 I'm 57 I just so 57
judgment were at 13 and I'm at a say I
my diet at the county - three to six a
week and they found some bright some
black stuff in my
I saw can you repeat that I'm sorry they
found some black spots in my brain at
the county hospital my rapist and they
say I'm I died from three to six weeks
they couldn't save it but they can help
me yeah you were in a mental hospital
for hall at the Exodus until 2014 you've
been in hospital for most of your life
yeah until now
they let me build my own but I got a do
get a nurse and stuff check on me all
the time right there by the Ford's the
nurse comes I gotta go see them and they
check on me and they put him a sheen on
my head
what are you where do you live right now
I just walk around he's out in the
street yeah
do you have any family
no only me I'm here you spent your whole
life in the hospital so it's hard to
have a family right yeah
I only know my sister but I don't know
know her I know I got a sister but I
already stay with my mama my mother used
to take my sisters to her curse my
auntie's health and keep me with her you
do mess around with any of the drugs
that are on the street yes I would not
was prostituting I did to us and then I
had sex and not called germs
so you started prostituting when you
came out of the hospital yeah 50 no 50
yeah
because of it yeah you know you you just
found out your brain cancer yeah I found
out in 2018 that I had a Marisa
okay it said what do you do for money
huh how do you survive I sit on the
ground some time to tell them dope they
could give me food or help or donation
so I II left all this and then sometimes
you work as a prostitute as well yeah
what's your view of life I mean did you
do do you think life is just cruel
no is what will you make of it but it's
cruel to me because I don't know nobody
I don't have no family no friends no cuz
I don't have friends because I feel like
different sometimes it's how I'm
[ __ ] or something I just want to be
by myself did he read he ever had
friends yeah in the hospital
my mama's friends I had my mama's
friends burrito thank you so much for
sharing your story
it's a tragedy it's not a story is for
real
you